What's that they see
in a riverful
Firstchech.
What a doche.
What do
she be?
Fore!
Foreign!
Should you not gain your wants, my soul, then Be not grieved,
but hasten to that banquet which
your Lord's bequath.
And when a thing for which you ask is slow to come,
then know that often through delay
are gifts received.
for
How's everyone? everyone doing
mashallah it's wonderful to be here with you all I'm just pulling up my uh the
Arabic document then we can inshallah
begin shortly
does everyone have uh the English translation.
Has everyone gotten a copy of that?
I don't think I don't see uh copies on the sister's side.
Okay, there's a few.
Okay. Do you Where did Can you tell the person next to you where you got
those? Cuz I think some some people might not have
uh the printed out copy.
If you don't have the printed out copy, it's also at the end of the PDF.
So the uh the handout that was uh that was uh sent as a PDF if
you go all the way to the end it's also there in PDF uh format.
So you're welcome to use
uh either one inshalla.
Okay.
Muhammad Sam.
Alhamdulillah. So, inshallah
in uh this series of classes
uh we're we're going to be looking at this uh short treaties
uh short but very full and meaningful treaties titled our character.
And this is a book that was written by uh our teacher
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala bless him and preserve him and allow us to benefit from
him. And he actually wrote this book when he was about 20 years old.
Uh when he was 20 years old, he kind of uh put these thoughts together
and I think that uh we'll all see how relevant
and accessible and understandable it is inshallah.
Uh and the book focuses on
three main areas
uh which we'll look at in the coming days inshallah tala.
Our character with Allah,
our character with our own selves
and our character with his creation.
Uh so uh you'll see when we talk about character in this sense uh that there's
a very deep meaning here and it's not just you know uh being courteous which is
a good thing you know having beautiful is a good thing uh but it's much deeper
it really is about the way of being our way of being and our uh interaction
and relationship with Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
our relationship with creation and our relationship with our own selves.
So the author begins the book with this verse of the Quran.
But whoever desires the hereafter and strives for it accordingly
and is a true believer, it is they whose striving will be appreciated.
Uh and this verse is hinting to us that the choice selecting this verse is really
helping us understand that this book is going to require spiritual struggle
striving for the whoever desires the hereafter and strives for it accordingly
and is a true believer.
It is they whose striving will be appreciated.
In other words, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will reward them generously.
So this book uh despite the fact that it's only a few pages,
it's extremely deep and it requires each and every one of us
to
really
commit ourselves
to putting into practice what the author is going to advise us.
Okay. And then he uh after quoting that verse of the Quran, the author then quotes
a couple lines of poetry.
Do not think that knowledge alone benefits
if one is not crowned by the Lord with good character.
This is really important.
There's a lot of people who might be knowledgeable, right?
We were I was joking with Mike earlier at the lake said, "Oh, you know, you've
studied." I haven't really actually studied that much, but he said, "Oh, you've studied a lot
now." said, "Yeah, but it's about putting it into practice.
It's easy to read books.
It's easy to, you know, uh uh sit in,
but what is really of the utmost importance is putting that knowledge into practice.
And the way that that knowledge manifests when it's put into practice is through beautiful character.
So do not think that knowledge alone benefits if one is not crowned by the Lord
with good character.
When you are granted a praiseworthy trait, then the distributor of provisions has truly selected you.
And this is a line of poetry by Muhammad Hafi.
Okay. So all of this is just kind of a preamble before coming into the introduction.
So then the author says all praise belongs to Allah, the generous, the beneficent.
Obviously in the name of Allah, the all merciful, the most merciful.
All praise belongs to Allah, the generous, the beneficent, whose benevolence is eternal.
I bear witness that there is no god except Allah, one without partner in a way
befitting of a servant who truly submits to his lordship and who finds true honor in
servitude to him. I also bear witness that our master, prophet and exemplar, Muhammad sallallah.aihi Wasallam
is the messenger of Allah.
He is the possessor of exalted character, the upright way and the straight path.
And as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in the Quran
that you, oh prophet Muhammad
truly have mastery
over magnificent character.
And all of the prophets and messengers
they were possessors of
degrees of perfection.
Now when we say that all of the prophets and messengers,
they are the most noble of all of Allah's servants and the most beloved of Allah's
servants. But even within their levels of perfection,
there are higher and higher degrees.
And so let's say for example,
you know, the the analogy
always uses is that if someone makes 10 free throws in basketball in a row, then
they have a perfect score, 10 out of 10 free throws.
But if someone makes 20 out of 20 free throws, they still both have 100%,
but one is of a higher degree than the other.
Someone who makes 20 in a row is of a higher degree than someone who's made
10 in a row.
So the prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam all of the prophets had perfection but the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam had all of good
character
each good character trait and every good character trait to its fullest manifestation.
The prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam had all of good character.
And it's not that he just had certain degrees of everything.
No, he had everything to the absolute fullest and perfect extent.
This is why Allah says
then the author quotes these lines of poetry from Imad.
He called us to the truth with revelation given by the all merciful.
the best message. We answered, accepted, and submitted to his command.
We hear and obey based on guidance and insight.
My Lord, make us steadfast upon guidance and truth.
My Lord, let us die upon the best of religions.
Amen.
Uh, oh Allah, send the greatest blessings and purest peace upon your beloved, our master Muhammad,
and upon his family and companions and all those who follow them with excellence.
And may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala make us among those who follow them with excellence.
A mean.
So all of this is kind of the introduction to the book and you can see
that it relates to good character and also this commitment
to the very essence of the message that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala revealed to the prophet
Muhammad sallallam.
So then the author says to proceed,
I present within these pages
exalted character and glorious traits
that are the character and traits of a believer who is actualized in the realities of
faith. Now that's an a very important sentence.
Who is actualized in the realities of faith?
And the author is going to show us that a lot of people say I'm I'm
Muslim. I'm Muslim and maybe and this is not a criticism of any particular individual but
this is actually speaking to a superficial understanding of our religion that people just think that
Islam is what we do in the masid.
Islam is you know prayer.
Islam is these particular things that are no one is saying are not important
but people just understand them at their most superficial level and they think that it's something
that you can compartmentalize
and it's just something that you put on you know you you do your bare minimum
and then everything else in life you just live your own way.
But what the author is going to teach us
is that the realities being actualized in faith is something that is absolutely transformative
and that when you have
this relationship with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that permeates your being,
it influences
the way that you smile.
It influences the way that you talk.
It influences the way what type of husband or wife you are, what type of son
or daughter you are, what type of parent you are, what type of employee you are.
It influences your integrity as a person.
It influences your integrity in private just as much as it does in public and so
forth. So, we're going to come back to this and I really want us all to
think about what does it mean to be actualized
in the realities of faith.
Faith iman is that which settles in one's heart and is confirmed by one's actions.
So, if someone says, you know, my iman is in my heart, that's beautiful.
Absolutely.
But it needs to translate into your actions.
It's not just something it's between me and God and no one else can interfere.
Yeah, at some extent to some extent that's true, but it should be something that manifests,
right? Something that is meant to blossom, you know, the the flower when it's it's beautiful
on the inside when the flower is kind of enveloped and wrapped up and then when
it gets to a certain point of maturity and the sun comes out, that beauty comes
out and is manifest.
That's iman. Eman is there but it should manifest and and uh that beauty should be
expressed.
Amen.
So faith is that which settles in one's heart and is confirmed by one's actions.
It is the removal of blamew worthy traits and the taking on of virtuous traits.
And really that is the summary of the spiritual path.
The summary of the spiritual path which he here the author is saying is really the
definition of iman itself is taking on virtuous character and removing blamew worthy character from our
hearts.
Okay. Noble character
which is you know
noble character has such a sublime and exalted place in Islam that the mission of the
seal of messenger sallallah.aii wasallam was only to perfect and complete it.
So the prophet sallallah.aihi wasallam who is the seal of messengers.
In other words, he is the culmination
and the fulfillment of all of the
missions of the prophets and messengers before him.
And in reality, it's all the same mission.
But he is the culmination of everything that they came with sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And he summarized his mission
as the perfection of noble character.
As we're going to see in this
as he stated,
I was only sent to perfect noble character.
So that teaches us it's very deep.
It's not just, you know, uh uh smiling at someone or being pleasant.
Someone's nice to you, you're nice to them.
No, it's something that is the actualization of the realities of iman.
And he's going to teach us inshallah in this book uh what that looks like and
what that means.
Therefore, a believer is bound to give it due consideration
since he will not become actualized in truly following the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
until he takes on the qualities that he was sent to perfect.
So it requires this deep commitment.
Okay. What are the qualities?
What are the what is the character that you, oh messenger of Allah
were sent to perfect?
And there are beautiful character traits that you know are easy for us to be attracted
to. But then there are other noble character traits that contain the heat of spiritual purification
and that require mujah
requires struggle
and it requires that you fight against your nefs
and it requires that you actually look deep within yourself.
For those who were here this morning uh at the reflection session after
sometimes
for a lot of us even having five minutes of silence
can be extremely uncomfortable.
So you're like I have to I have to think I have to
organize my thoughts. And many people actually chase distractions
and in the most extreme forms, they'll even give into addictive behaviors or maybe not give
into addictive behaviors, but become caught up in addictive behaviors because they're running away from
being with themselves and feeling what it is that they're going through.
But that's essential for us to grow.
And I remember one of our teachers,
he said that it requires a great amount of courage
to look inside of yourself and to see what's really going on.
So he says that you will not become actualized in truly following the prophet until you
take on the qualities he was sent to perfect.
And that requires a lot of introspection.
It requires a lot of thought and consideration.
This is the very basis of our eminence and pillar of our advancement
is noble character.
Is noble character. And one of the students of Imam Malik, one of the great imams
of Islam, he said, I spent 20 years studying with Malik.
And he said 18 of those years
I focused on his I focused on his
I focused on his state with Allah.
And then two of those years I spent focused on taking from his outward knowledge his
knowledge of his knowledge of hadith and so forth.
And then he said,"I wish I spent those two years taking from his and
because outward knowledge there's a lot of people who are very knowledgeable
and who might have access might be people of fatwa and people of technical sciences and
which is extremely important don't get me wrong but where are you going to find the
state with Allah that Malik had
that's rare.
That's rarer than that other kind of knowledge.
Where do you find someone whose very way of being
resembles so closely that of the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam that merely being in their presence
is a lesson in and of itself before they even speak.
Being in their presence
brings your heart closer to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this is why there were some of the sahab
they became Muslim by merely seeing the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Eman entered their heart just by seeing him or sometimes by very brief interactions with him.
One of the stories of the head of the tribe of Do the tribe that Abu
was from. He was the head of his tribe and he came to Mecca
because he was from outside of Mecca
and he spent time sitting with the other nobles of Quraysh because they're all kind of
tribal
uh dignitaries and so forth.
So the whole night
they were talking to him about the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Don't you dare listen to one word this man says.
If you even talk to him one time he's going to put a spell on you
and this that and the other.
He said the whole night they got me really scared.
Then they were giving people like cotton and things that they put in their ears.
If you if you see him put this in your ears don't let him even speak
to you.
So then he said the next day I went to the Kaa and I saw the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and I put the stuff in my ears and and he said
and he was praying there and he was making dua or whatever it might might have
been that in that particular time the prophet was doing and he said to himself he
said listen
I've come across some
magicians and people who do kind of sorcery and slight of hand and even
you get a very negative feeling.
Those people, they have a a way about them that is very dark
and and it's like toxic for your soul.
So he saw the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam praying there at the worshiping Allah
said this is beautiful.
He said I'm an intelligent person.
I can differentiate between right and wrong and truth and falsehood and what is good speech
and what is sorcery.
So he took the things out and he said, "Teach me a little bit of what
you have." So the prophet wasallam came and he said, "Come sit with me."
And he taught him.
He just recited the suras of Quran that we all know and learn as as children.
Immediately became Muslim. brief interactions with the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
These are people and his inheritors sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
They're people who
true good character
is something that is etched into their very being.
Most of us and it's this is how we're all works in progress.
Most of us try to act on good character which is good but for them it's
something that's already part of the fabric of their being.
It's deeply embedded.
I remember I was with one of our teachers
from Mecca
and this is actually in in uh in Miss Saga in Toronto and he gave this
at a masid and he's you know a visiting scholar from Mecca
this beautiful man from the city of the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam a descendant of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and it was a beautiful
when the they were introducing him they mentioned some of his teachers and so forth and
someone in the crowd
was just like, "Oh, you know, these people are
Sufis,"
you know, and it was just like, "Here we go."
Right? And and a lot of it is and and if you're a person who's heard
this word in a negative connotation, please feel free to come and talk to us.
We'll clarify. I remember someone said it to He's like, "Hey man, people are saying you're
a He like looked around like it was like the worst word in the Sufi."
And I was like, "Okay."
And he was like, "No, man.
You're meant to be more offended.
Like you should be I was like, "What does that mean to you?"
So like people who worship graves and stuff, I'm like, "I don't worship graves, so I'm
not worried about it."
But a lot of people, they have this negative connotation when they hear that.
Anyway, so there was someone in the crowd there who as soon as he heard who
he had studied with, he's like, "Oh, these are some Sufis, man."
So he came up and he was like, "Please uh tell everyone in the masid that
this person's a Sufi and these are bad people."
I was like,
"This is a fellow Muslim from
he's a vis just have the basic decency to say, "Thank you very much for coming."
And then someone else came up to him.
He was like, "What are you doing about the king over there and what's going on
politically and this that the other and are you speaking out?"
And then he said to him, he said, "This is like politics.
That's better if we talk about it outside of the masid.
Let's talk about Allah and his messenger here in the masid."
And then the man just kept kind of berating him.
And I'm like, "This person's a guest.
Like, what's wrong with you people?"
And I was so upset at how they had mistreated him.
and he saw that I was, you know, visibly bothered.
He said, "What's wrong?"
I'm like, "Habib, look at how they're talking to you.
People coming up to you as if you're responsible for what's going on in Saudi Arabia
or people say like," and he was like, "The prophet sallall alaihi wasallam went through much
worse."
He was totally cool.
Like he was not bothered in the least.
He said the prophet went through much worse.
Like what? Don't be don't sweat it.
And it was like, I'm trying to learn how to have that character that comes much
more naturally to you.
And as I imazali says, that's real good character.
There might be someone who gives a lot of money.
So people say he's generous, but he's not actually generous.
And there might be someone who is generous of spirit who has nothing to give, but
they're actually a generous person.
That's real good character.
And this is what the author is telling us that we have to dig deep
and work on our hearts and souls to actualize our iman so that even if it
doesn't come naturally to us now that it eventually eventually will come naturally to us inshallah
tala.
And then he says here this is the very basis of our eminence
and it is the pillar of our advancement.
Now, that's an extremely important sentence because a lot of us as Muslims, particularly in a
postc colonial world,
and he's actually going to speak to this very directly
in a postc colonial world, a lot of people, whether we know it or not,
we're still
experiencing
the aftermath
of many Muslim Muslim countries, even if we're converts and maybe we're not from Muslim majority
lands, that's a separate point.
But we're still as an ummah
experiencing the aftermath
of when many Muslim countries were colonized.
And even if we're from countries that are not Muslim majority, but they've been colonized, we
can still understand
some of the aftermath of what that did to people's sense of identity,
people's sense of value and worth
where maybe the language was changed.
Maybe people started to think we're backwards and they're advanced.
We don't really have progress.
And in the 20th century, particularly in the last century,
a lot of
Muslim scholarly discourse
was centered around
how we come back
from
this suffering that the ummah experienced and is still experiencing in a very real way, in
a in a kind of different way, but experienced
by being colonized
and defeated
and even being in some ways intellectually and spiritually broken.
How do we come back from that?
So many people say no, we have to be politically like them.
We have to be economically like the western powers and the post-enlightenment powers.
We have to be in terms of our technology and education and so forth.
A lot of people will internalize
no no you know what we are backwards.
And what the author is saying here and it's extremely powerful
is that the very basis of our eminence
of
our
ascendancy our elevation. not elevating ourselves over others but actually being elevated in the sight of
God.
And the
and the pillar of our advancement and revival
comes from good character.
And someone might say, "Oh man, that sounds like very nice language and flowery kind of,
you know, it sounds nice, but how's that really going to translate into the world when
you see what's going on with the ummah?"
We're going to look at that shortly, inshallah.
Keep that question in mind.
We'll look at it shortly.
But he's going to back up this uh understanding
okay that the basis of our eminence and the pillar of our advancement is in our
character and I'll tell you a story of one of those sahab it's one of the
most amazing stories
and
we need to study their lives because if you look at the umah today
the odds were even greater against them.
If you look at the battle of Bedr, you look at the battle of, you look
at the battle of the trench,
the odds were not in their favor outwardly.
But look at how in a short period of time Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala brought about
the greatest amount of change
and the spread of Islam in this very short amount of time particularly compared to other
periods of history and other movements and so forth.
There's something miraculous
and that's why even western thinkers will say that the most influential human being in in
human history trying to look at it from an objective lens is the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. We already know that but even other people from the outside recognize that because
it's nothing short of miraculous.
And when you look at the the character of the you see it one of the
his name escapes me now but he was captured by the disbelievers
and essentially they kept him captive
and eventually executed him
and the Meccans uh uh captured him and while they captured him
they uh they he had asked for a knife, which is essentially a razor to
uh groom himself and and uh take care of his cleanliness and groom himself properly.
And scholars say why was he grooming himself if he was going to be executed?
Because he wanted to beautify himself for his meeting with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Like even just to think about
the state of someone's spirit
who is able to do that in that moment.
They're amazing people. It's easy to talk about it, but he was living it.
So they brought him a knife.
He said, "I want to, you know, you've had me captive for a while.
I want to uh trim my and and groom myself."
So they brought him a knife.
While he had the knife, one of their children, the children of the people who had
held him captive and are about to execute him, one of the children was playing and
came into his lap.
So, one of the women
saw that child in his lap and he's got this knife.
So, he looked at her completely calmly.
He said, "Are you scared?"
He said, "Us, the companions of Muhammad were never treacherous.
Your child is safe with me.
I would never harm your child."
Said, "We companions of Muhammad were not treacherous."
That woman who saw that and witnessed that eventually became Muslim.
And she says, "I never saw anything more beautiful than the day that I saw him
grooming himself and when he had that knife before he was executed."
He said, "Us, the companions of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam, we do not we're never treacherous.
We would not harm a child.
We would not do that to someone innocent."
And they executed him.
But what does that tell you about the deep level of He could have said, "Okay,
you got to let me go, right?"
Like the movies. I'm just trying to get out of here.
No, no, no.
There's a a standard.
There is a level
of
that we hold to the no matter what, no matter how anyone else treats us, we
do not go below that standard.
So then the author quotes this line of uh poetry
which is a line of poetry by a contemporary Arab poet Ahmed
peoples. You could even say
are peoples or civilizations
or communities.
Peoples are nothing other than their character.
If their character is lost,
then they too are lost.
And that's really powerful
because what makes a civilization
I mean even the word civility being civil
is part of civilization.
Civilization is not just military might.
And even in this very country, you had people at the highest levels of presidency and
and political power who were trying to fight against the military industrial complex
that they realized you're trying to make the military into something that is an economic benefit.
You have an economic interest in war.
That's not what military power is meant to be used for.
So there was a loss of integrity.
And there were people who were trying to within our own government at a time that
were trying to fight against those forces
because they realized
power is not what makes a civilization great.
Military strength, it's important.
It's a part of, you know, what makes a a a civilization.
and so forth. But it's not everything.
You know, you have all of these people weapons of mass destruction and so forth in
the hands of people
who are not great people.
So what is it that makes a civilization?
It's their character.
It's their integrity.
It's their work ethic.
It's their trustworthiness.
It's their honesty.
The prophet Muhammad Sam
years before he ever even received revelation was known in Mecca
as
truthful and trustworthy.
That's what they would call him al
the trustworthy one.
They knew him by that quality and it was so firmly
uh understood and experienced by the Meccans that even people who didn't believe in his message
would give their most valuable
uh possessions when they would travel they would entrust it to the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. You know, when you travel back in the day, people didn't have, you know, security
deposit boxes and banks and things of that nature.
So, they had to have people that they trusted.
They say, "This is a big pouch of gold.
I need to leave it with someone.
I can't travel with it."
Who's not going to skim off the top,
you know? It's a big pouch of gold.
Someone just take a couple coins off the top.
The guy's not going to notice.
So you need to keep it with someone who even if you would never notice they
have such a degree of trustworthiness that they would never take something away from you.
That was the prophet Muhammad wasallam for the Meccans
years before even receiving revelation.
Why?
Because it's of the utmost importance that that character that integrity
precedes the message.
As we say in in in you know our societies, talk is cheap.
And as we're going to even look at when we educate children, children learn through their
eyes more than they learn through their ears.
Do what I say, not as I do.
Now, children are going to follow what you do.
As our people, they're going to judge your integrity based on your character.
Peoples are nothing other than their character.
If their character is lost, then they too are lost.
I remember someone uh a scholar commenting on visiting one of the great
uh the great bastions of Islam in Sham.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala inshallah restore Sham and Yemen to their full glory and benefit
for the ummah and all of the lands in the east and west.
But he once went to the marketplace and the marketplace is a very good place to
gauge
integrity.
So he went to the marketplace and he was going to buy from, you know, a
vendor who was selling fruit or nuts or something of that nature.
So he was about to buy from him and the man said, "You know what?
I've sold enough today.
Go to my friend over there."
His friend is actually what we would call a competitor.
Go to him over there.
he didn't sell as much today.
Go buy fruits from him.
And he said, "Mashallah."
That's a level of integrity where someone's able to say, "You know what?
Alhamdulillah,
Allah has blessed me today.
I've made more than enough.
My my brother over there hasn't sold as much.
Go buy something from him."
He said, "Alhamdulillah, the ummah is in a good state."
He said, "I came years later and I was about to buy from someone."
And the competitor yells from across the way goes, "His goods, his fruits are no good.
Come over here. I got the good stuff."
He said, "Ah, something changed."
Peoples,
the good, the benefit, the success, the advancement of a people's
is in their character.
When that's lost,
then all of the infrastructure and all of the economic power and all of the milit
that all just crumbles.
And this is why
we have an extremely
important
job to do
in this country and beyond.
But we're here.
We're residents of, you know, the United States and Canada.
And maybe people have come from other places as well.
Wherever Allah has placed us, we have a responsibility to the land and to the people.
I remember one of our teachersh
was saying to and I happen to be fortunate enough to be in the room and
hear this advice. He said, "When you teach people about Islam in America,
teach them Islam in a way
that shows that it is a restoration
of their values.
It's not something foreign and alien that you're bringing in from the outside, but you're actually
taking part in restoring
the good values that might have been more prevalent not so long ago.
Where people used to say things like sir and ma'am to their elders.
Where people would say things like please and thank you.
where people had respect for one another, where people
were could could trust each other more.
There's been a breakdown.
Everyone is in their own little island.
That Islam is actually a restoration
of the good things that used to be more prominent in society.
And that's the job that we have to do.
And that's why uh restoring character
is of the utmost importance for all of us.
We'll continue looking at the author's words inshallah tala.
So then he says, I compiled these noble character traits and exalted qualities and listed them
so that they may serve as a reminder of what we must expect from each other
come together for and cooperate in.
In other words, that we have a collective
consciousness at the level of our umah that we have a job to do, that we
have a standard to live by and that it's not just something a few people do,
but we all want we want to be elevated in the sight of Allah and we
want others to rise up and be dignified and elevated as well.
Each of these character traits can be explained in great detail and there are many Quranic
verses and noble hadiths that emphasize these traits.
Our goal here as mentioned is only to remind.
Perhaps there will be an opportunity in the future to speak in more detail regarding each
trait.
After first strengthening their belief, Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to these
noble character traits, values, and ideals which are uh which are also sorry uh oh no
actually uh is it wi is or are we'll get back to that if anyone knows
which is also uh a means for strengthening belief.
And by the way, for those of you who this is a rough draft as you
can see uh inshallah we'll continue to refine it until it's uh suitable for for publication
inshallah tala.
So uh we are in dire Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to
these noble character traits, values and ideals which is also the means for strengthening belief.
So what the author is saying here
is that we need the first and most important thing we need to do is strengthen
our iman
is strengthen our iman.
And that's actually what we focused on today uh in the reflection session this morning is
reflecting on marvels of Allah's creation and the wonders in his beautiful design that allows us
to grow in iman and see the wisdom that Allah has placed within
the creation that all point towards him subhanahu wa ta'ala
and when we strengthen our im we become
more like
the the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam infused them with the highest degrees of faith and certitude
such that you see many examples of the Sahabah even when they faced something as jarring
as death
they were not perturbed
which is a very high level of faith there's a natural degree where a person is
does not like
you know the the the does not like death.
We're not morbid. We don't have this fascination and obsession with death.
But they realized that it is a step in the journey and it is a step
closer to the beloved.
So when it came
they were not shaken by that and that was due to their iman.
Okay. After strengthening iman, Muslims today are in dire need of holding firmly to these noble
character traits. And they're also they have this sort of uh mutually reinforcing way of strengthening
iman as well.
Regardless of whether one is a scholar, craftsman, ruler, trader, or worker, each needs to apply
these character traits in his dealings with his Lord, companions, and himself.
And those are actually the breakdowns of the chapters.
Our character with Allah,
our character with his creation, and our character with our own selves.
Indeed, we have suffered much harm by losing these noble character traits to divisiveness and animosity.
And we have experienced many woes because we abandon them.
You see that the vast majority of Muslims today neglect the rights of others, are rigid
in their views, arrogant, and corrupt in their dealings.
There is no power nor ability saved by Allah, the exalted, the Almighty.
We know with certainty that without coming together,
cooperating and uniting,
we will not be able to resist our enemies nor achieve any victory.
And this is uh and we'll end with this inshallah
and pick up tomorrow from this point.
But this is what is interesting about
the author's
scope of concern. He wrote this when he was 20 years old.
He wrote this in 1403
of the Hijidi uh calendar.
We're now in 1447.
So that's what 44 years ago.
Is my math right?
44 years ago
when he was 20 years.
No. Am I right?
Yeah. Subhan Allah.
Okay. So 44 years ago when he's 20 years old
and he has this concern at the level of the umah
at the level of the entire um and he's actually talking about and as the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam informed us
that at in every century Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will bring forth
someone who revives the rei the the religion of Islam for the ummah.
And he at 20 years old is already concerned about bringing around a level of revival
of this entire dean and of the realities of iman at the level of the entire
ummah. He could have spoken just about Yemen.
He could have spoken just about his local.
He could have spoken about Arabspeaking countries in the Middle East, but he's actually talking about
the entire um and that for us to be able to resist our enemies and to
have this revival
and to have uh this reawakening,
we need to understand
at the deepest levels.
So the scope of what we're talking about might actually seem that we're just talking about
good character
which seems to be very nice
and maybe something that's seen as secondary or tertiary.
But what the author is saying is no this is at the very foundation
of what benefits the entire ummah and which is the core
message of the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam's mission.
So we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to allow us to benefit
uh from these character traits that he's going to uh share with us that Allah subhana
wa tala allows us to have that level of determination
and courage
and commitment where we put this knowledge into practice in such a way that the realities
of faith become manifest at a level where we become servants of the entire um and
servants of everyone in creation.
Alhamdulillah.
We'll stir them.